since 2008 the Cloverfield franchise has
introduced moviegoers to a multiverse of
stories in which just about anything can
happen with that in mind let's dive into
the three films and follow its
unexpected timeline from the crowded
streets of New York City to the endless
expanse of space Rob Hawkins and Beth
MacIntyre wake up in best fathers
apartments in New York on the morning of
April 27th 2008
Rob with his camcorder on teases Beth
because she's never been to Coney Island
and they decide to take a trip there
that same day since the video that
documents the events of Cloverfield is
recording over Rob's tape from the Coney
Island date the audience sees glimpses
of it throughout the film at the end of
the movie we see footage of Rob and Beth
on a ferris wheel upon closer inspection
you can see an object crashing into the
ocean as Rob films but neither of them
seem to notice some people assume that
this object is the film's monster or
something containing the monster however
other fans theorize that it's a portion
of a satellite that agitates the
hibernating beast a little less than a
month after the Coney Island trip on May
22nd Rob and Beth are on the rocks and
Rob is preparing to leave New York City
to take a new job in Japan his brother
Jason throws a going-away party for him
and Rob's friend HUD begins filming
farewell messages from the guests
unknowingly taping over the Coney Island
date HUDs recording of that night makes
up the bulk of Cloverfield early in the
film HUD captures Rob and Beth arguing
after she brings a new man to the party
Beth angrily leaves and heads back to
her apartment suddenly is Rob's brother
is trying to cheer him up the building
is rocked by what seems to be an
earthquake forget the world and hang on
to the people that you care about the
most
Oh
what the hell was that after a brief
power outage the partygoers turn on the
news and learned that an oil tanker is
capsized near the east coast as a guests
make their way downstairs the head of
the Statue of Liberty flies through the
air and skids to a stop on the street
panic ensues as a giant monster makes
its way through the city destroying
everything in its path to make matters
even worse small creatures are detaching
from the monster and attacking anyone
within striking distance Rob receives a
message from Beth who says that she's
trapped in her apartment building he
decides to venture across Manhattan to
rescue her for better or worse his
friends Lily Marlena and HUD who is
still behind the camera come along to
help after 3:00 a.m. now on May 23rd
they get caught in the crossfire of the
military in the monster scrambling for
safety they eventually escape into the
subway where the creatures that detached
from the monster attacked them one of
them viciously bites Marlena they barely
escaped the subway and emerge into a
shopping center that's been converted
into a makeshift field hospital by this
point Marlena is looking pretty rough
and states the obvious it doesn't take
long for staff in hazmat suits to hustle
her into a medical tent where her body
explodes Rob still focused on saving
Beth persuades the military to let him
leave but he's warned that the
government will begin bombing the city
at 6 a.m. to kill the monster Rob Lily
and HUD ultimately find Beth and make it
to evacuating helicopters and they all
lived happily ever after
not really after Lily's helicopter takes
off the one carrying Rob Beth and HUD
crashes when the Beast attacks it but is
killed by the monster and with no time
left to escape Rob and Beth huddle under
a central park archway the doomed couple
films their goodbyes while bombs fall in
the city as the film ends a whispered
voice says help us suggesting Rob and
Beth may have survived when played
backwards the same voice says it's still
alive hinting that the creature also
survived before the events of 10
Cloverfield Lane Howard Stambler hires a
local man Emmett to wit to help him
build a bunker under his farmhouse in
rural Louisiana the film never gives a
definitive year but around 2014 a young
girl named Brittany goes missing a
couple years later a man in a woman
named Michelle who will learn more about
soon pieced together that Howard
actually abducted Brittany and forced
her to live in the bunker this is made
clear when Michelle finds the word help
scratched
skylight at some point Howard killed
Brittany presumably because she was
attempting to escape this brings us to
the harrowing story of Michelle after a
bad breakup she leaves New Orleans and
is driving near Lake Charles Louisiana
where she's in a car accident
she later wakes up in the underground
bunker of an extremely strange man
Howard informs Michelle that there's
been an attack of some kind which has
contaminated the air and is preventing
them from leaving the shelter she soon
meets Emmett who also witnessed some
version of the attack before heading for
the bunker and the two share of
suspicions about Howard weeks pass and
the trio seems to relax into some sense
of normality
despite Howard's angry demeanor and
paranoia everything changes when
Michelle crawls into the ventilation
system and discovers Britney's help
message together she and Emmett make a
plan to escape the bunker by
constructing hazmat suits out of
anything that can find Howard ultimately
discovers that Emmett took a pair of
scissors as part of this effort and
threatens both of them with a barrel of
perchloric acid Emmett quickly claims
that he was the only one stealing things
and apologizes unfortunately Howard
hasn't really mastered the art of
conflict resolution I accept your
apology desperate to escape the bunker
Michelle tries to secretly finish the
hazmat suit only to be discovered by
Howard in the struggle to escape
Michelle kicks over the barrel of acid
towards Howard he's badly burned and the
acid reaches a lamp Court which starts a
fire that spreads throughout the bunker
Michelle crawls through the ventilation
system and ultimately escapes to a car
abandoned by Leslie a woman who visited
the bunker earlier but was not allowed
in due to lesions all over her skin
Howard is presumably killed when the
bunker explodes as she prepares to leave
the farm Michelle sees an alien
spacecraft in the sky over the fields a
creature detaches from the ship and
pursues her she eventually takes shelter
in Howard's truck as the tentacle tries
to grab her she fights back by crafting
an improvised Molotov cocktail setting
the ship on fire and causing it to fly
away Michelle finally drives away and
tunes into an emergency radio broadcast
which tells survivors to meet in Baton
Rouge however anyone with military or
medical experience should head to
Houston to join the fight to retake the
southern seaboard from the
Asia she turns the car around and drives
toward Houston the Cloverfield paradox
takes place in 2028 when the earth is
rapidly running out of energy as fuel
and electricity is rationed people have
resorted to using dangerous devices to
siphon power the governments of the
world unite for one final plan to save
humanity
the Cloverfield station a spacecraft
built by a coalition of global agencies
that will activate the shepard particle
accelerator
if the shepard works it will provide
earth with an unlimited new supply of
energy among the scientists chosen for
the mission is ava Hamilton a
communications officer who lost her
children in a house fire caused by a
device she was using to siphon power
there are those who are not convinced
that the Sheppard is the best way
forward some propose that activating the
accelerator could trigger something
dubbed the Cloverfield paradox this
would open doorways to other universes
which could then lead to all manner of
terrifying alien life attacking earth
eagle-eyed viewers will notice that the
critic of the project on the news mark
Stambler shares the same last name as
Howard Stambler from 10 Cloverfield Lane
however the films never draw a direct
connection between the two characters
the Cloverfield team lives on the
station for approximately two years
taking the mission into 2030 they have
not yet managed to achieve a stable beam
in the shepard and they are running out
of fuel for more attempts after many
disappointments the shepard finally
seems to work
unfortunately when everything appears to
be stabilizing a power surge causes a
failure of the accelerator and creates
chaos throughout the Cloverfield as the
crew tries to restore order Hamilton
realizes she can no longer locate earth
well it's baby blue full of angry people
people can you find it along with earth
it seems that a gyroscope essential to
navigating the station has vanished
from this point on things become more
and more bizarre first of all the crew
discovers a mysterious woman inside one
of the station's walls and her body is
fused with the wires of the station the
woman Mina Jensen makes incredible
claims about the crew members including
that she and Hamilton are close friends
despite the fact that Hamilton is never
met her before
shortly after this Russian engineer
Volkoff dies and spits out a clue of
worms that was previously just minding
their own business living happily in
their enclosure on the ship then irish
engineer Mundy loses an arm inside a
wall without any bleeding or pain Mundy
severed arm later reappears and seems to
have a mind of its own it drags itself
on the ground and eventually writes a
message saying that the crews should cut
volkov open Oh
despite the creepiness of the arms
advised they cut open volkoff's corpse
and find the gyroscope in his chest with
the gyroscope back in place the crew
locates earth then learns that the
Cloverfield station apparently crashed
into the ocean two days ago the
conclusion is clear the Cloverfield
paradox is real and they are in an
alternate dimension with their situation
now understood the Cloverfield
scientists begin working on a solution
to return to their own dimension the key
to their plan is an algorithm developed
by engineer Tam but repairing the
station proves to be extremely dangerous
both Tam and Mundi are killed in the
process of mending the Cloverfield and
Commander Kiel sacrifices himself to
eject part of the station so the rest of
it will hold together in the film's most
emotional plotline Hamilton discovers
that her children are still alive in
this version of Earth she decides to
stay in the alternate universe to keep
her children safe despite the fact that
there's another version of herself
already living there suddenly Jenson
violently turns on the crew she knocks
out Hamilton fatally shoots the station
dr. monk and wounds the German engineer
Schmidt after Hamilton wakes up Jenson
explains that she can't allow the
station to leave because she needs the
Shepherd to save her version of the
world the two began a fight to the death
that ultimately ends when Jenson is
sucked out of a broken window into space
Hamilton then decides that she must
return home to her own dimension because
the children from this earth are not
replacements for her own with Jensen
dead Hamilton makes a video message for
her alternate self she warns her about
the accident that killed her own
children and sends detailed plans for
how to rebuild the successful version of
the Sheppard which will save her world
Hamilton and a wounded Schmidt returned
the Cloverfield station to their
original dimension and reactivate the
Shepherd beam as they reestablished
communication with earth they announced
that the accelerator is finally working
properly and they head home in a capsule
craft while all this has been happening
Hamilton's husband Michael has been
dealing with some serious problems on
earth when the Sheppard triggered the
Cloverfield paradox it did indeed open
doors to another dimension to which
giant monsters arrived
Michael begs the space agency to keep
his wife on the station to avoid the
carnage but it's too late as the ship
arrives an unwanted visitor makes its
monstrous presence No
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite film franchises are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]